bonjour à tous je voulais parler
quelques temps au nord a sorti la très
très peu de temps un honneur 9 lite qui
à mon avis est un peu le petit frère du
nord 7 x un produit vraiment similaire
mais qui en tout cas est plutôt pas mal
là j'ai la chance de l'essayer au mwc
mobile world congress à barcelone
j'ai un peu envie de le voir parce que
c'est vrai que je comprenais pas trop la
différence entre le 7x et le 9 lite
parce qu'il me semble être tous les deux
sur la même
la même positionnement tout cas en terme
de prix en termes de produits
[Musique]
c'est vrai que des chars en termes de
prise demain je trouve pas mal vous avez
un capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est situé à l'arrière ça sert économique
la position est pas mal vous avez une
double caméra ici on 13 mégapixels et 2
mégapixels et vous allez retrouver
exactement la même chose de l'autre côté
13 mégapixels et 2 mégapixels en façade
les effectifs 2 mégapixels c'est pas de
faire des photos super qualité mais
vraiment devenir de venir travailler sur
le flou pour les faits évoqués sur le
mode portrait qui développe énormément
ça huawei du moins au nord parce que là
on est sûr au nord même si c'est la même
boîte l'a compris et c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont le mettre à l'avant et à
l'arrière sera un produit d'entrée de
gamme donc c'est plutôt pas mal
côté design je trouve pas mal fichu vous
avez un écran 5,65 pouces à l'avant le
petit logo honorant bas la caméra au bon
ça marchait pas mal c'est du lcd c'est
une dali ps 2160 par 1080 pixels un
format 18/9 c'est vraiment le format qui
s'est imposée en 2017 mais qui va
continuer en 2018
côté processeur vous avez un kirin 1 659
à l'intérieur on manque d'accord pas
dans les processeurs mais pour un prix
d'entrée de gamme très bien la faire une
batterie de 3000 millions paire eur 3
giga de ram 32 gigas de stockage que
vous pouvez monter grâce à une carte
microsd
vous avez soir la possibilité d'avoir un
double lecteur carte sim soit à carte
sim et microsd c'est au choix la charge
c'est du micro usb
vous avez un bout tous cas point de
rejoindre c'est un smartphone d'entrée
de gamme
jce tient plutôt pas mal personnellement
c'est pareil je sois pas la grande
grande différence avec le 7x si c'est
effectivement d'avoir un produit qui
tourne sous android aurait eu 8 points 0
tout neuf c'est vrai qu'il est pas mal
c'est vrai que c'est un joli produit qui
se tient bien qui fait son effet il
fallait effectivement qui est une
innovation pour au nord sur ce début
2018 fin 2010 est pourtant réelle
fatigue bon bah c'est pareil je reste un
peu perplexe pas pour repositionnement
mais ça leur fait un produit plus dans
la gamme un produit qui se tient un
produit de qualité que je trouve moi pas
mal pas mal franchement en termes de
prise en main il pas mal à l'arrière
vous avez un dos en verre sur les
petites traces de loi mais c'est pas
d'un go
c'est pas d'un go ça marche les caméras
pour le job les faits évoqués
sympathique c'est pas non plus un truc
de dingue mais voilà c'est vraiment
c'est vrai que ça marche plutôt pas mal
petite différence que vous avez par
rapport aux celtics c'est effectivement
des bords qui vont être plus incurvé une
double caméra l'avant vous n'êtes pas
sur le 7x
mais c'est vrai que sinon au niveau
software au niveau 1 au niveau logiciel
intérieur c'est la même chose à la
regarder typiquement je prends un
honneur c'est x dans les mains vous avez
une seule caméra à l'avant un dos
plastique de côté vous avez un dos en
verre donc effectivement à chacun son
école va qu'on préfère elle doit envers
moi et été traces de doigts ça me
dérange un petit peu mais bon peut-être
effectivement un petit peu moins un peu
moins classieux celui-ci à l'arrière un
petit peu plus cheap os le 7x tels que
le 9 lite fait mieux son son effet
je vous dis il ya la différence ici le
capteur d'empreinte digitale est passé
de la même manière côté façade avant
pour le logo nord en bas voilà on est
vraiment sur les produits qui sont quand
même vraiment similaires l'intérêt pour
le nord c'est par un petit produit en
plus en entrée de gamme avec une double
caméra à l'avant avec un dos en verre
pouvoir séduire encore plus de
consommateurs vient vraiment en
complément de ses gammes sur l'entrée de
gamme justement mais c'est quand même
dingue c'est effectivement ailleurs les
deux produits hyper rapprocher
mais bon pourquoi pas c'est pâques en
tout cas effectivement ça permet aux
consommateurs d'avoir plus de choix sur
cette typologie de produits parce que de
toute façon que ce soit le honor 7x
l'honneur 9 lite
ils sont exactement au même tarif donc
voila un petit peu pour une prise en
main rapide ou en w c'est de ce nord 9
lite des dites moi ce que vous en pensez
à ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tandis que c'est un produit qui pourrait
vous intéresser
marc qui m'a tout ça en commentaire
comme d'habitude vous invite à mener sa
vie pousse à vous abonner parce que la
guilde remémore de smartphones
énormément de choses on va continuer de
faire un tour gardez vous allez voir il
ya plein plein plein de choses cool à
voir donc restez connectés merci à vous
et puis je vous dis à très bientôt
et puis n'hésitez pas comme d'habitude
parler de tout ça autour de vous 2 au
nord de ma chaise laissée des pousses
d'oubli pas souhaiter meilleur et à très
bientôt
chang
[Musique]